good morning everyone this video come to
you in to discussions of new
technologies first one is the iPad this
Wednesday apparently Apple introduced a
tablet PCs something that no one ever in
the history of time has ever thought to
create really this is not to say that
I'm not interested in it I think it's
very interesting I do however think that
if it takes off it will take off in ways
that we don't expect kind of like the
way that blogs destroyed the format of
newspapers the iPod destroyed the format
of albums and movies don't work
particularly well if you're watching
them on your desktop computer I think if
the iPad works it will work in ways that
we don't expect and probably could not
understand right now like I think it's
gonna make a lot of sense for study
guides with interactive tests and
diagrams and stuff but I don't think
it's gonna make sense for like a regular
textbook I'm an early adopter of eaters
I've been using ear eaters for about
five years now and so it's been a lot of
time with them and I want to say that
there are a couple of reasons why books
are always gonna be better than eery
ders here's one reason imagine that this
is an iPad you're not gonna do this to
an iPad I also like the flip ability of
books especially nonfiction where I can
be like oh what was that thing that I
was reading last chapter oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah there it is I also like
this about books the battery life on
this thing kicks ass now again I'm not
saying that there's no place for e-books
in the world I'm just saying there are
advantages to the current format
speaking of new and exciting ways to
experience media YouTube just launched
the rentals program I decided to check
out the system see how it works and
watch a movie in the process since I
already have Google Checkout set up
linked to my Google account it was
really easy just popped up and I clicked
and it was I also I'm in America people
in other countries don't have access to
it so sorry y'all so you just click Play
and the movie starts running and then
you get it for 24 hours I watched the
movie on my desktop I paused it every
once in a while and did work and had it
running in the background sometimes and
it was pretty enjoyable experience I
generally don't like to watch long-form
content on my computer what I think is
something that you do please do
recognize it's not going to really work
unless it really works with people's
televisions not with their computers
because people don't like watching
long-form content on their computers
overall though it was a good experience
but I have to say the $3.99 seems a
little bit steep to me I pay
$5.99 a month for Netflix I get about
five DVDs a month in the mail and I get
unlimited streaming this model to me
does not really make sense unless I'm
getting more for my money or I'm paying
less now for a quick review of the movie
that I watched which was called The Cove
warning this is disturbing first let's
review it as a movie then ideologically
as a movie fantastic one of the most
high-energy documentary films I've ever
experienced and I've watched lots of
documentary films I would watch it again
the pacing was great the story was great
expended the story in good broad strokes
there was depth there was breadth and
the results in the end of this like
kick-ass teams espionage is more
disturbing than anything I have ever
seen in my life in real life or in film
it was definitely worth three dollars in
99 cents and I really hope that the
filmmakers get what they deserve which
is plenty of money to continue doing
this kind of work I would suggest it I
encourage you to go watch it if you
think that you're not going to go crazy
it's 399 I think it's only available in
North America and it's only available
until this Sunday so now are you gonna
have to get it on Netflix
as for ideology I generally feel like we
as humans are often right and we are
often wrong very rarely do I come down
an issue and I'm like this is not right
and you are wrong what's going on with
the dolphin harvest in Japan is not
there isn't a word for it the closest
word that I can come to is ender Scott
Card's Xenocide if you got time and
you're not of too delicate sensibility
go give the Cova watch maureen I will
see you on Monday
you